bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo on va reparler
de doctor strange 2 j'ai pas mal cogité
dans mon coin d'ailleurs un petit peu
désolé pour le retard le trailer est
vraiment hyper riches il ya plein
d'informations et je suis convaincu
qu'on peut déceler quand même pas mal
d'éléments du film avec évidemment il
faut quand même prendre un peu de recul
un cela reste un trailer marvel c'est
très bien nous manipuler avec avec des
faux scène des trucs rajouter des trucs
enlevé et cetera rappelez vous du fameux
clin d'oeil de spider man no hero en
tout cas j'aimerais que nous nous
concentrions sur doctor strange car
après tout bas c'est son film en fait
peut y avoir mille caméo cela reste lui
le personnage principal et franchement
il y a quand même pas mal de mystères
qui l'entourent déjà si je vous dis
qu'il y aura nightmare dans doctor
strange days et qu'il aura même
possiblement un rôle important est ce
que vous me croyez tout d'abord je
préfère le préciser mais évidemment je
vais vous partager ma vision personnelle
des choses et mes idées un tout
peut-être vrai tout peut-être faut peu
importe cette vidéo c'est simplement le
résultat de ce que j'ai remarqué dans le
trailer et de ce que j'en déduis par
rapport à tout ce qu'on a pu voir pour
nightmare la première chose qui m'a mis
la puce à l'oreille c'est comme tout le
monde le fait que notre docteur strange
parle du fait qu'il fait des cauchemars
le mot nightmare est clairement
prononcés et ce n'est pas du tout anodin
mais en vrai cela va même plus loin que
ça car un élément me perturbait pas mal
dans le trailer et c'est le fait que
doctor strange n'est jamais seul on en a
parlé dans la vidéo analyse du second
trailer mais strange est toujours
accompagnée de soi america chavez et
christine palmer ou bien de wendat
sachant qu'il est d'ailleurs l'élément
protecteur du groupe entre guillemets
dans le sens où palmer n'a aucun pouvoir
et qu'america chavez est encore jeune et
bien je le vois mal les laisser
vagabonder dans le multivers et pourtant
il y à de nombreux plans ou strange se
retrouvent dans des endroits inconnus et
où
il est seul et si on regroupe ses plans
c'est toujours dans la même dimension
celle qui est complètement déstructuré
et c'est là que cela devient intéressant
pour moi car effectivement cette
dimension sinistre koch toutes les cases
de l'horreur déjà strange s'y retrouvent
seuls comme si il était dans un
cauchemar tout est absolument
déstructuré au point que cela en est
même irréel par exemple c'est idiot 1
mais le symptôme sancto room est
normalement au milieu de la ville
entouré de bâtiments et ici ce n'est pas
le cas du tout mais surtout il y a des
codes visuels qui ne sont pas à ignorer
déjà 2 1 la déstructuration ensuite les
couleurs ternes de la dimension est le
plus important les nombreux crâne qui
jonchent le sol hélas si vous êtes un
fan des comics vous avez déjà compris ou
stremme se trouve il s'agit pour moi à
1000% de la dimension de nightmare soit
la dimension des rêves on retrouve tous
les codes visuels des comics d'ailleurs
il est important de le rappeler mais à
l'origine dr strange 2 devait être
réalisé par scott derrickson celui qui a
fait le premier docteur strange et de ce
qui avait été déclaré à l'époque c'est
que nightmare devait être le vilain
principal du film effectivement sam
raimi a repris le projet tout a été
réécrit mais bon je ne suis pas sûr que
tout le travail de d'ericsson a été jeté
à la poubelle ils ont dû garder
certaines choses c'est un élément qui
reste important a rappelé donc voilà
rien qu'avec ça pour moi cela confirme
presque à 100% la présence de nightmare
dans doctor strange 2 mais ce n'est pas
tout il ya encore moyen d'aller plus
loin depuis que j'ai revu le trailer et
que je suis convaincu de la présence de
nightmare une idée un peu folle mais
survenue et je me dis que pour le mc eu
ce serait vraiment stylée que ça arrive
enfin une idée folle
pas tant que ça au final parce que vous
allez voir que ça se passe quand même
sur des éléments et des choses logiques
nightmare serait en fait un docteur
strange et pas n'importe lequel
esi
notre docteur strange quand il est dans
la dimension des rêves il n'est en fait
pas tout à fait seul il fait face un
autre strange un strange qui est bien
plus sombre le sinister strange et le
truc c'est que d'accord je veux bien
qu'il y ait nightmare dans le film mais
à quoi il va servir normalement c'est un
ennemi de ce trail jeu mais étant donné
tout ce que va nous proposer le film
c'est difficile de se dire que nightmare
en ferait partie elle est où sa place ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que wendat
ou une variante est attendu pour être un
antagoniste du film nous avons aussi le
fameux gargan tôt cela shuma-gorath le
rôle des illuminati semble encore plutôt
flou ils ont l'air d'être quand même
plutôt gris et centraux dans le film
donc voilà elle est où la place de
nightmare dans tout ça alors il est
quand même possible que nightmare soit
connecté à tous ces éléments du genre
qu'il est manipulé wendat dans ses rêves
qu'il soit le disciple de gargan tôt
cela shuma-gorath comme dans les comics
qu'il soit le strange pointé du doigt
par bordeaux dans le trailer et du coup
par extension les illuminati mais bon il
n'y a rien qui permet d'affirmer
réellement quoi que ce soit en revanche
je suis convaincu qu'il va servir au
développement de notre docteur strange
pourquoi justement car il est un variant
de notre docteur strange il est un
steven strange mais en bien plus sombre
et c'est là pour moi qu'il ya matière à
développer tout d'abord faire de
nightmare un docteur strange jeu plus
sombre rappelle une pratique qui aime
beaucoup sam raimi s'est proposé une
sorte de miroir à notre héros je ne vais
citer que ces exemples car je les trouve
déjà très parlants spider man avec le
spider man noir de venom haute octavius
et quand il devient docteur octopus ou
bien norman osborn et le bouffon vert
bref l'idée que dr strange va devoir
faire face un lui même beaucoup plus
sombre comme un miroir déformant et
franchement c'est parfait avec le
concept de variants ensuite pour moi il
ya un autre aspect pertinents qui peut
potentiellement démontré l'importance du
sinistre strange pour le développement
de notre docteur strange c'est qu'en
fait il ne serait pas au final tant que
ça un ennemi forcément on se dit si mr
strange voilà c'est un strange sombre il
doit être maléfique c'est l'opposé d'une
autre c'est forcément le méchant et bien
au final peut-être pas tant que ça et en
plus de ça il ya des éléments dans le
trailer qui sont un peu étranges prenons
le cas de what if qui permet de bien
illustrer ce que je souhaite démontrer
la série nous l'a prouvé strange peut
faire les pires atrocités dans le fond
il n'est pas mauvais entre guillemets
nous faisons face à une différence de
vécu strange ici n'a pas perdu ses mains
mais son coeur ce qui va le conduire à
devenir le suprême dr strange un strange
plus sombre et plus fort néanmoins cela
ne va pas l'empêcher d'être un allié de
taille pour affronter hull tron et
sauver le multivers et c'est là le point
intéressant c'est que strange est ce que
ce soit un variant ou non c'est pas
quelqu'un de foncièrement bon ou mauvais
il est capable de proposer le pire pour
en tirer du bon c'est un être nuancée
presque une sorte d'anti héros en soi
alors si nous revenons sur le sinistre
strange il est fortement possible que
nous ayons en face de nous un docteur
strange beaucoup plus sombre de par son
vécu et sa vision mais pas forcément un
antagoniste et c'est là qu'il pourrait
servir pour le développement de notre
docteur strange
je vous disais qu'il ya des éléments que
je trouve étrange dans le trailer et
bien justement ces éléments appuierait
cette idée prenons le cas du dard gold
normalement c'est rwanda qui le
possèdent elles l'utilisent pour
comprendre et maîtriser ses pouvoirs et
certainement pour retrouver ses enfants
sauf que nous voyons notre docteur
strange utiliser le dard gold dans la
dimension des rêves donc normalement
loin de wendat et en plus de ça il
utilise la magie du chaos c'est un
élément qui est vraiment bizarre car si
l'on s'y penche un peu docteur strange
je prends le temps d'apprendre dudar
gold pour maîtriser une nouvelle magie
et en plus de ça dans la dimension des
rêves d'ailleurs il semble accompagner
de quelqu'un difficile de dire
précisément qui mais bon les pôles
ressemble pas mal aux costumes du
sinistre strange et en plus de cela avec
ce que je disais au début c'est
normalement le dr strange nightmare et
sa dimension du coût est ce que notre
docteur strange ne serait-il pas en fait
en train d'apprendre du sinister strange
et c'est un point réellement pertinente
car comme vous le savez le dark auld
n'est pas un livre conseillé pour
apprendre la magie c'est un artefact
capable de rendre fou son lecteur qui
permet d'appréhender les magies les plus
sombres la magie du chaos est d'ailleurs
une magie considéré comme beaucoup trop
puissante un pouvoir que détient la
scarlet witch et qui dépasse même ceux
des sorciers suprême sauf que comme je
vous disais docteur strange est un être
nuancée capable d'utiliser le pire pour
en tirer le meilleur c'est justement ça
qui fait que le docteur strange est si
puissant et que l'ancien croyait en lui
il est capable de briser les règles pour
trouver une solution contrairement à un
bordeaux qui est terriblement rigide en
rencontrant le sinistre strange ou le
possible nightmare notre docteur strange
après andré les connaissances plus
sombres de son homologue pour en tirer
le meilleur il est même possible que le
dark gold que ce trench manipule soit
celui d'une autre dimension et qui
appartiendrait à ce sinistre strange
mais bon voilà tout est possible par
rapport à ça néanmoins cela ne s'arrête
pas là et je vous propose de revenir sur
le premier poster du film sur ce dernier
nous faisons face à troyes dr strange et
s'il y en a trois ce n'est pas anodin
évidemment sur le centre nous retrouvons
notre dr strange à droite nous
retrouvons le singstore strange qui
symbolise un strange plus sombre et de
l'autre côté nous retrouvons le defender
strange qui est apparu lui aussi à
plusieurs reprises dans le second
trailer et là je ne peux m'empêcher de
m'imaginer que ce strange symboliserait
pourquoi pas un strange qui on va dire
serait est un petit peu plus lumineux
pourquoi je dis ça déjà car defender
strange est un héros si l'on s'intéresse
à ses origines en soit il n'est pas si
différent de notre docteur strange juste
il fait partie d'une équipe de super
héros alors évidemment on est dans le mc
où il y aurait donc une adaptation et
une réécriture surtout que defender
c'est aussi une série marvel netflix
donc cela peut porter à confusion
donc voilà bref mes choses intéressantes
se defender strange fait partie du
combat où nous voyons un monstre multi
vers celle composée de bandelettes et il
semblerait même qu'america chavez va
possiblement le sauver en invoquant l'un
de ces portails multi versed évidemment
ce qui va être intéressant c'est que
notre strange va le rencontrer et tout
comme pour le sinister une nouvelle
version de strange va faire son
apparition un strange qui seraient
potentiellement plus lumineux que le
sinister strange et ce qui en découlera
c'est qu'il y aura un échange entre les
strange docteur strange est un héros qui
apprend constamment et s'il est amené à
rencontrer ces variants mais il est
évident qu'il voudra en apprendre plus
sur eux et du coup par extension sur lui
même un moyen qui va lui permettre de
tirer le meilleur de ces variants et
tout ça là ce n'est pas incohérent je
dirais même que quelqu'un l'a déjà vécu
pour moi
une peine narcissique et auto
satisfaisante néanmoins depuis ces
rumeurs
[Musique]
et ici nous pouvons nous interroger car
effectivement il semblerait que le
defender strange ne passera pas un bon
moment dans le plan ou america chavez
semble le sauver nous voyons qu'il
possède plusieurs blessures au niveau du
visage et plus tard lorsque nous faisons
face au docteur strange zombifiés nous
retrouvons ces mêmes blessures sur le
visage sans parler du fait qu'il possède
la même coupe de cheveux dont notamment
la queue de cheval et les vêtements
c'est effectivement le defender strange
que nous voyons là mais que s'est il
passé c'est très difficile à dire mais
personnellement j'ai l'impression qu'il
l'est dans la dimension des rêves nous
retrouvons les mêmes couleurs et la
neige ou particules de la dimension mais
surtout quand nous le voyons se
déchaîner dans sa sombre heures nous
voyons des crânes élément qui fait
partie du code visuel de nightmare alors
est-ce que le sinister strange aurait
vaincu le defender strange le truc c'est
que cela reste un trailer ils nous ont
clairement montré ça pour nous hype et
en plus un c'est clairement stylet à un
string tombe dit fier à un peu dark mais
voilà c'est un peu difficile de définir
véritablement ce que veut dire cette
transformation cela peut être une
illusion ça peut être une vision ou
peut-être est-ce vraiment une véritable
transformation mais bon c'est très
difficile de le dire au moment mais si
mr strange est bel et bien nightmare et
bien nightmare et le souverain ultime de
sa dimension des rêves donc il en
quelque sorte tous les pouvoirs là bas
et ce qui est d'ailleurs intriguant
c'est que s'il s'attaque au defender
strange pourquoi de l'autre côté
aiderait-il plutôt notre docteur strange
dans tous les cas il est clair que notre
docteur strange aura un rôle clé
évidemment c'est le personnage principal
de ce second film à va lui permettre
d'évoluer et puis de s'affirmer en tant
que sorcier dr strange 2 promet d'être
une véritable d'un gris et
personnellement j'ai plus que hâte en
plus y'a tellement de mystère vraiment
c'est fou cette vidéo était quand même
un peu folle je suis plutôt curieux de
voir votre réaction peut-être que je
fais un peu trop loin mais voilà je
voulais vraiment vous partager ma vision
ce sur quoi j'ai cogité ce que j'ai
imaginé donc voilà j'espère que ça vous
a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
laisser un petit pouce bleus évidemment
et puis un commentaire et surtout
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour ne
pas louper les prochaines vidéos et puis
bah voila quoi que le line up sont avec
vous cet argot rock allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]